>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michelle Choe: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So we're going to move
on to the second panel,
which is on ownership
and contractual issues.
The goal of this panel
is to explore the state
of contract law vis-à-vis
software-enabled everyday products
and how contracts such as end user
license agreements impact investment
in and the dissemination and
use of everyday products,
including whether any
legislative action is necessary.
So before we start, we should
first introduce the new member
to our section.
>> Erik Bertin: Good morning.
I'm Erik Bertin.
I'm the Deputy Director
for Registration here
at the Copyright Office.
>> Michelle Choe: And we should
also have the new members
on the panel introduce
themselves and their affiliations.
So, if we could start
with you, Mr. Perzanowski.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: My
name is Aaron Perzanowski.
I'm a Professor of Law
at Case Western Reserve
University in Cleveland, Ohio.
I've been thinking and writing about
issues concerning consumer ownership
of digital goods for a long time.
>> Michelle Choe: And Mr. Harbeson.
>> Eric Harbeson: I'm Eric Harbeson
from the Music Library Association.
>> Michelle Choe: OK, great.
Thank you.
So, after reading the comments
we've received in this area,
we've identified two areas
of particular interest.
First, what are the legal
or practical rationales
for employing end user license
agreements or other types
of agreements in the context of
software-enabled consumer products?
And second, are such agreements
having any practical effect
in the marketplace in terms
of limiting the availability
of exceptions and limitations
in the copyright act?
So, if anyone would like to
start addressing one or both
of those issues, that'd be great.
So, Mr. Bergmayer.
>> John Bergmayer: Yeah.
So, I think one of the issues
with software, in particular,
is that where it goes beyond
contract law is that if the seller
of a software product or a
software-enabled product is
in some way saying that you never--
the buyer never actually
owns the copy.
That doesn't just affect the
relationship between the seller
and the buyer, it has
downstream effects
because the first-sale doctrine
then never kicks in and people
who are not privity to the sales
contract between the seller
and the buyer would also
be infringing copyright
for later distributions.
So I think that is one of the
particularly dangerous areas
with the notion that a seller
of a software product
can reserve ownership.
And also, I think you'll see
in a lot of the comments,
there was agreement that the
law doesn't need to change
but different people have different
idea of what the law means.
When I say the law it
doesn't need to change,
I think that these parallel
doctrines that have come
up where software vendors uniquely
among all copyright holders have the
ability to sell you
something and say
that they didn't really sell it you,
that has no basis in the statute.
It defies common sense and legal
logic and yet we've allowed it
to grow up in the software
industry to sort
of arrange its business models
around this legal concept
where in other areas
plenty of other sellers
of copyrighted products have
tried to do the exact same thing
and they've been smacked down by the
courts, you know, the foundational
for sale cases about the
attempt to withhold rights--
resale rights from customers, the
people who have given people sample.
Music have tried to say,
well, you can't resell this
because you don't really own it
and courts have taken the
very common sense view
that if you're transferring a
physical item to someone for keeps,
that means they own it and just
sort of boilerplate language
in a sales agreement
between a seller
and a buyer can't really change
that basic economic reality.
And it is this-- you know,
this is the issue that sort
of got me involved in this area.
You know, I first started looking
about this stuff and the Vernor case
which I think came
out the wrong way.
And I think if we just revisit
these doctrines which are judge-made
and have no basis in the statute,
we can undo a lot of the real
and potential consumer harm.
>> Sy Damle: So, can I-- I mean, so,
you know, when I re-read Vernor--
I mean, Vernor is based on an
older case from 1977 called Wise
which didn't involve up a software.
It involved a motion picture prints.
And with the court basically said
there was-- I mean it reached--
it sort of reversed the
convictions I think in that case
on other grounds but it
did say that, you know,
the court discussed a sort of
VIP prints of motion pictures
like staying [inaudible]
and said that,
you know, those could be licensed.
And so I'm just wondering
what you say about--
I mean, just to your point that
this is something that's unique
to software, I'm just wondering
whether you could address sort
of why and it's a reasoning.
>> John Bergmayer: There absolutely
can be situations where I sort
of transfer physical custody
of a physical item to a buyer
or another person where they don't
really own it but I think there have
to be facts to support that,
it can't just be routine
like I just sort of add it to
every single thing that I sell,
there has to be some sort verifiable
requirement that they destroyed
after use or that they return it,
or there has to be some
sort of reality to that.
It can't just be something
that anytime anyone buys a consumer
product, the example that I pulled
out was-- in our comments
but I could have found it
in probably any product is
the Nest thermostat license
which simultaneously says that you,
the buyer, don't really own this,
you don't own the copy of
the software which, you know,
is a physical thing because
copies are always material objects
but it also describes
you as the buyer.
And it's just contradictory and it's
just put there as a matter of course
in all software that
is sold to consumers.
And I think that's the problem,
not that there might be exceptional
circumstances where, yeah, you know,
if you're giving it back or if
you're really just renting it
or it's in a unique market that
has particular characteristics
like film prints.
But I think it is the
universalization of this,
what should be an exceptional
circumstance, that's the problem.
>> Sy Damle: So, just a couple
of points I'm just curious about.
So-- I mean in Vernor there was--
as a recall, there was a requirement
that purchaser destroy
the copies when they--
the original copies when
they purchased the upgrades.
So there was-- the court did mention
that sort of restriction which seems
to me similar to what was--
>> John Bergmayer: Yeah.
But at the same time you can't
just say that you're required
but there's no actual enforcement.
I mean, as far as I
know, if you just say
that just adding a requirement of
distraction to a contract is enough
to get you into that special
circumstance, then people just
that every time and it
won't really be enforced.
I think the point is that there
has to be an economic reality
that controls whether or not a sale
has taken place, not merely words.
>> Sy Damle: So, just
a follow-up question.
So I wonder if you could-- So what
the software folk say is that, well,
if we can't license it, then
things like academic versions
of software become unviable
where, you know, you sell someone,
you know, $149 copy of Microsoft
Word with the understanding
that they're not going to use
it for commercial purposes
if you don't have some sort of
license that enforces that, right.
>> John Bergmayer: So two things.
You can still have a contract,
just the contract only applies
to the person who ended--
who entered into the contract
and it doesn't apply to all
potential downstream users.
So if you do sell something to
someone at a discount and then just
up and reselling it into the general
market, you can use contract law
to go after them but I think
it would be inappropriate
to go five owners down the line and
start using copyright against people
who have no idea, never
entered into that contract.
And second, you know, yes, there
are certain business models
that might be easier for sellers
if they have certain legal rights
but that doesn't-- that's
not a slam dunk argument
that those rights should exist and
in fact in other areas like books
and textbooks we do have special
academic editions or pricing
and it seems to work just fine.
There is no concept that
when you buy a textbook,
you don't really own it.
And in fact, you know,
I think anyone who used
to be a student thinks it's great
that you can buy a used textbook
or sell your textbook
when you're done with it.
And I just don't see why we need
special software-specific doctrines
except when they are
specifically codified by statute,
where there's notion that you
don't own a thing that you bought,
does not come from the statute.
That is entirely a
judge-made doctrine.
>> Michelle Choe: Why don't
we move on to Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: Thank you.
So for ORI where this--
the relationship of contract
to those issues most obvious
is the first-sale doctrine
which applies to owners of copies.
And so if you have software
embedded in a device
and the software is just
licensed but not sold,
then the first-sale doctrine
arguably does not apply
to that piece of software and so
you can't transfer the software
when you're transferring
the rest of the good.
And so that makes it
difficult to sell--
to sell the product in
the secondary market.
And so that's, you know,
really where we see that issue.
And as John said, really
the economic realities
of the transaction are that
when you buy the device,
you're buying the copy
of the software,
you're not expected to return it.
And it seems that obviously
that, you know, if you're able
to keep the device for its useful
life, let's say if it's 10 years
but let's say-- you know, then if
you want to after five years sell it
to someone else who could
benefit from the other five years,
you should be able to do so.
And so-- But when you
have a contract--
when you have this
contractual restriction,
not only do you have
problem that it--
that could be breaching a contract
but on top of that you're not able
to take advantage of
the first-sale doctrine.
So, figuring out the
license piece is--
or this contractual
piece is critical
to allowing the alienability of
this piece of personal property.
And then just-- secondarily,
you know,
we had talked in the last
session and a lot of people talked
about reverse engineering
and interoperability and how
that isn't-- have the
copyright law so clear on that
and we'll talk a little bit more
about that in the next session.
But I just wanted to point
out that almost every piece
of software that's
distributed whether just
as on the standalone basis
or if it's in a device,
the license agreement almost
always contains a prohibition
on reverse engineering
for any purpose.
So, you know, it's all well and
good that the jurisprudence says
that it might not be a
copyright infringement
but if you have these pervasive
license agreements that prohibit you
from engaging in that activity,
obviously there's a tension.
Now, the question is, getting
to second question, you know,
what has been the real
impact on that?
Now with respect to these
restrictions on reverse engineering,
the license restrictions, you
know, there has been litigations,
the Bowers v. state case.
And one of the issue there was--
is the license prohibition
on reverse engineering is preempted
and, you know, the truth is that--
you know, in that case, two
judges say not preempted,
one judge said yes it is preempted.
I think that that's one of
those really complicated areas
that I would hope the
study would start delving
into about this relationship of
when our contract term is preempted
by the copyright act
and starting to think
about that and look at that more.
But I think that that is
an issue that, you know,
when you counsel clients, you
have talk about and you say, well,
there's this argument,
there's that argument and,
you know, do what you need to do.
And I have a feeling a lot of--
you know, there are some people who
do go ahead and reverse engineer
and sort of hope that it's in the
event that there's a litigation
that will be found to be preempted.
And I imagined there are other
people who are more risk averse
and are not reverse engineering
because they don't
want to take that risk.
>> Sy Damle: Sorry.
Is it your understanding that a
violation of such a contract term
against reverse engineering would be
just a breach of contract or would
that be-- is that somehow tied
to copyright infringement?
>> Jonathan Band: Well, I think
there's case law that would suggest
that it could be both,
meaning if it seemed to be--
if it's a valid restriction
in your--
you know, I think there is a
case law that would suggest
that it would be not only
both breach of contract
and a copyright violation--
copyright infringement.
>> Sy Damle: Sorry.
Even if it were otherwise fair use?
I mean, if the reverse engineering
were deemed to be fair use,
it would still be infringement?
>> Jonathan Band: Right.
I could-- Again, the argument would
be because you're going against--
you don't have-- you
might have the copyright--
you would have the copyright
but because you have--
you know, you agreed not to do it
right, you know, I'm not-- I would--
I think it would be-- you know, it
would be an issue to be determined
but I think that certainly there
would be some who would argue
that that would be an
infringement as well.
>> Michelle Choe: Sort of a
step back from legal issues
and getting into the specifics.
In terms of these licenses,
how prevalent are they,
how often do they have sort
of restrictive language
about reverse engineering or
restrictive language that sort
of specific to copyright?
>> Jonathan Band: I wouldn't say
that I obviously haven't
done a complete survey
but I would be shocked if
the vast majority of programs
that are distributed,
you know, whether by--
you know, I will be surprised
if it didn't have a--
every license that I have
seen, every software license
that I have seen includes a
prohibition on reverse engineering.
It is-- You know, as John would
say, you know, this is boilerplate.
You just automatically include it.
I'm sure all of Mr.
Zuck's members when they--
of the vast majority when they
distribute their apps, I mean,
it's just-- you know, it's part of
the template, you prohibit people
from reverse engineering.
>> Michelle Choe: Well, just as
sort of a data point, you know,
not to bring up the four-letter word
but in the rulemaking proceeding.
We have had a finding that
for ECU and automobiles
that there were no licenses
associated with those at the time,
so we're-- it would be very
helpful to us to have sort
of specific examples of industries
or specific contracts themselves
that are attached to
these products and sort
of the restrictive covenants
that are in those agreements.
>> Jonathan Band: Also I know--
because I can't speak from the--
for automotive industry because
I'm not as familiar with that
but I certainly know on the computer
area almost whenever you're buying
certainly-- whenever you're--
when you're acquiring the computer
and then certainly whenever you're--
you know, all those licenses
that you're always clicking
out whenever you're-- you know,
any update you get, you're clicking
on a license-- of course I never
bother reading that just like none
of us ever read any of those
licenses that we're clicking
on our agreement to but
I would be surprised
if all those software license
did not include a prohibition
on reverse engineering.
>> Michelle Choe: I'd like to open
that question to everyone just
to get a sense of because, you
know, we understand that this--
these exists in general
software context but to sort
of narrow the inquiry into sort of
software-enabled consumer products
and how prevalent this is in that
context would be incredibly helpful.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Yeah, I mean
I debated with a response simply
because I don't have any data, I
don't have any information in terms
of how prevalent reverse
engineering prohibitions are
in embedded software licenses
as opposed to other types
of software licenses and not
to mention the difficulty
that we talked about in the
first session about making
that distinction between
software and embedded software.
But I actually will not disagree
with Mr. Band in terms of the fact
that the reverse engineering
prohibitions, you do find them
in many, many if not virtually
all software licenses.
And there's a reason for that,
which is most people don't
care about reverse engineer.
When you get a mass market
software included and embedded
over how many people
want to go ahead
and reverse engineer the software
in their toaster or their thermostat
as example was used before
or something like that.
It allows software companies to
go ahead and with a certain level
of comfort be able to include
their software in those products.
So there are significant benefits
not only to the software companies,
not only to the hardware
manufacturers
but most importantly their
benefits to most consumers.
>> Michelle Choe: So, along those
lines, what are the benefits
and the drawbacks of having
these license agreements attached
to the products then, beyond sort
of-- both in the copyright context
and outside of the
copyright context?
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
So you're taking
about beyond just reverse
engineering now in terms
of the value of these licenses.
I mean, I think it's important
to note that, you know,
the software license will
be-- is one component in--
if we're talking embedded software
in the larger scheme of things
in terms of the hardware itself.
And if you look at a lot of these
software licenses, for instance,
we talked about transfer
and prohibition on transfer,
most of them actually
do allow transfer,
they may have certain conditions
attached to those transfers
and a lot of those have to do
with, you know, with consumer--
you know, consumer protections
perhaps more than anything.
I think it was interesting that
the gentlemen from public knowledge
and I think maybe Jonathan
as well, maybe,
talked about the fact there's value
in having to return the product
or having to destroy the product.
And if I was really, really
interested in the fact that the--
from gentleman from public knowledge
talked about, his big issue was
that there was no actual
enforcement of that.
And, oh my gosh, I mean,
you know, public knowledge,
I understand represents consumers
but now it's encouraging
software companies to go knocking
on consumer's doors and
saying, "Did you destroy that?"
And I don't think that's
anything anybody wants to do.
It is certainly not consumers
and not the software industries.
So, in terms of having to
return the software to prove
that it's a license makes
very little practical sense
and it's just a burden on
consumers and frankly a burden
on the software owners, also, having
to destroy it, also, you know,
comes with its difficulties as
well in terms of, OK, you know,
you then have prove that it was
destroyed or something like that.
And when you're talking about a
lot of these software products
at the pace that technology
is moving, do you really need
to destroy that software to
prove that this is a license
at some point, very, very
soon that software is going
to be obsolete anyway
and have to be updated?
I mean, we talked about a little bit
of how quickly software is updated
and how quickly technology moves.
So, why do we need these
sort of artificial--
to include these artificial
requirements
to show that something license.
I do think the Vernor test is the
good test, is an accurate test
of when something-- when the
software license should be enforced
under the copyright
law when it shouldn't.
>> Erik Bertin: So can I
ask you the question I ask,
I think it was Mr. Band, which
was if someone violates a ban
on reverse engineering,
if that reverse engineering
would otherwise be fair use?
Is that just a violation
of the contract
or is that a copyright infringement?
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Yeah.
So I would have a hard
time believing
that would be copyright infringement
when you have a court saying
that this is fair use.
I mean, I don't see
how that's possible.
I don't know that we've had any
litigation in that area, but--
so I take a slightly or maybe
totally different view than Mr. Band
on that particular issue.
>> Erik Bertin: I assume
that's an answer
that would make Mr. Band happy.
[ Laughter ]
Keith Kupferschmid: So
advocating for each other.
That was a joke for the record.
[ Laughter ]
>> Michelle Choe: Why don't
we move around the room
since we have a lot of cards up?
So we'll move on with Mr. Harbeson.
>> Eric Harbeson: I
do want to speak.
I just want to make sure that
I'm going to be going back
to the top level question,
so make sure that were.
I want to thank the office for
letting me come here to speak
because I am representing
the Music Library Association
which you might not expect to see
at a hearing called
Software-Enabled Consumer Products.
And we're here because
we believe that the--
not withstanding its
name the study is bigger
than software-related
consumer products.
And this is-- So I'd like
to invite the room to take--
to go to one upper level of
abstraction and think of this
in terms of the broader way in which
we're allowing contracts to affect--
allowing nonnegotiable end
user license agreement,
especially to create a
parallel system of copyright
without the limitations and
exceptions that are built in.
And we've-- you've already been
discussing this to a fair amount.
I want to raise our issue which
is that in many cases, there are--
there is music and especially sound
recordings, which have for years
and years and years libraries have
been collecting this music on disc
and then tape and then
tape and then disc again.
And we've lent it and we've
done-- we've taken care--
we've preserve that we've done of
all of the things that libraries do.
Along comes the digital distribution
services such as iTunes and Amazon,
then you have Spotify of the world,
and in some cases we have found
that music distributors are deciding
only to distribute their music,
their sound recordings
especially, through these services.
I'm actually just talking about
sound recordings not musical works,
only looking to distribute
their sound recordings
through these services.
Now, in the case where they are also
distributed on a physical medium
that we can purchase,
that's not a problem.
We can buy them.
We can distribute them
the way we always have.
But, when they're only distributed
through this digital
distribution services
and that's the only way
the public can have access
to these sound recordings, that
creates a big problem for libraries,
and this has been on
the verge of a trend.
It's not quite there yet.
It is not, however,
parade of horribles.
It's actually in the
record we have--
you know, on the record a link
in our comments, we have a link
to a list of works
that we've collected
that are being distributed this way.
In particular, I'd like to put on--
to discuss one that we discussed
in our comments which is the case
of a Grammy Award winning sound
recording of Gustavo Dudamel
in the Los Angeles Philharmonic.
We've raised this in copyright
office proceedings before.
This is a Grammy Award winning
sound recording produced
by Deutsche Grammophon in which a
couple of our members spent a lot
of grant money trying to track
down the license for this.
It was only being distributed in--
by iTunes and the iTunes software
license makes it impossible
for libraries to enter into
the agreement because it's
for end users only when
libraries are not end users.
Furthermore, even if we could
enter into the agreement,
it doesn't let us do
anything with it.
So, our-- my colleagues at the
University of Washington spent a lot
of time tracking down the--
someone who could give
us-- give them a license.
They went to iTunes and
iTunes said you have
to talk to Deutsche Grammophon.
Deutsche Grammophon, you have
to talk to, I think, Universal.
And finally after a large train of--
a lot of work, they finally
tracked down, I think it was--
yes, it was Universal
Music Group which--
and I quote, the article
that my colleagues published,
"They agreed to license the material
under the following conditions
that no more 25% of the album's
content could be licensed
and the license would be valid
for no more than two years.
Furthermore, a $250 processing
fee would be charged in addition
to the unspecified licensing
fee that would have been more
than the processing fee."
So now we're over $500
for a two-year license
for not even the entire work for a
Grammy Award winning sound recording
and for work that the public
could purchase for $10 on Amazon--
well, purchase for $10 on Amazon.
Libraries do important work.
We cannot allow these
kinds of licenses
to circumvent the good
work that libraries do.
Right now the problem is only in
music libraries that we know of,
with sound recordings, but there are
numerous companies that are putting
out digital works and who knows when
they'll stop making CDs or DVDs.
I keep hearing about the
forthcoming death of the CD.
So, I-- we are advocating for a
very narrow exception to the law
that would allow those-- the
provisions of nonnegotiable licenses
to be-- to not be enforceable
only in the event that they are--
that there is no other means
for a library to acquire it.
And I can talk about that later.
Thank you.
>> Erik Bertin: Thank
you, Mr. Harbeson.
I'd like to ask a broader question--
and maybe this speaks
to the issues you raised
or others may want to jump in.
And that's the question
of privity of contract.
I mean, if you're taking a license
for the software that's embedded
in the product that you purchased,
what impact if any does that have
on the downstream users that
Mr. Band raised earlier.
Are they bound by these
licensing agreements,
do they run with the product itself
or is this an issue of contract
as Mr. Bergmayer suggested
that there's a distinction
between licensing and contracts,
which I'm not quite sure I
see the difference there?
>> John Bergmayer: To
answer that question,
I think it's pretty simple.
License is just permission
to do something you otherwise
don't have the legal right to do.
And conditions can be put on
that, but it simply unilateral.
There's no need for there
to be a meeting of the minds
or consideration on both
sides, or anything like that.
A contract is a contract
that you like--
you learned about in law school.
I think in software typically you
have one agreement which is both.
You know, just to answer sort of
your questions, I think the failure
to distinguish between a license
and a contract and the allowance
in the software context uniquely of
sellers to reserve ownership rights
of physical goods that they sell
leads to issues like the core
in MDY ended up saying, "OK,
well, we don't want to say
that any single tiny minor violation
of a contractual term
automatically leads
to copyright infringement
in the case of software.
Because in the case of software if
you don't own it you did a license
to operate it and you need--
and you simply need a license to use
the product in its ordinary course
and the court really
saw the coincidence
of that would be pretty bad so they
said, OK, well, you actually have
to look at it and you have to
determine, is this a covenant
on a license or is it a contractual
condition and you have to sort
of piece together and
like dissect the document
to figure out the difference.
And I think that is a sort
of very difficult task,
which you could avoid if you simply
get rid of the underlying problem
of the reservation of ownership
because in the normal course
of action, like for example
if I'm a movie theater
and I violate the contracts
that allows me
to publicly perform the movie and
then I publicly perform it anyway,
the idea that that kind
of contractual violation
could give rise
to a copyright infringement
is not a problem.
It only becomes a problem
when you need a license simply
to use something in its
ordinary course of operation,
which by all sort of common
sense you thought that you owned.
So, I'm not sure if I'm sort
of getting at the distinction
that I see between a license,
but I think that the failure
to properly distinguish and
understand what a license is
versus what a contract is
by including deferral
appellate court says has led us
to this very difficult legal
situation where it is very difficult
to tell where what consumer
rights are and whether or not
and which particular
provisions might run
with the chattel as it were.
>> Michelle Choe: So what would
be your solution to that issue?
Would it be sort of, you know,
clarifying that regardless
of these licenses that, for example,
in the conducts of Section 109
or Section 117, you
know, that, you know,
the consumer would be considered an
owner in those context, at least?
>> John Bergmayer: Yes.
I think that is the solution.
For the most part consumers who buy
physical items whether it's media
or consumer products, I think
they typically own those products.
Routinely, judges and the common
law has historically always said,
you know, things like, "Oh, you
know, this isn't really a sale,
it's a thousand year lease,"
like that doesn't work.
Like it doesn't matter that the two
parties agree amongst themselves
and their sophisticated party is
that negotiate and sort of write it
down in a piece of paper.
It's not true.
You can't make something that is
false true just by writing it down.
And you can't take something that
is a sale and label it not-sale
and then have all sorts
of legal consequences
that affect people including
people who are never even privity
to that original agreement.
>> John Riley: Is there a
distinction now between the types
of contracts that, you know,
attempt to expand what we think
of as copyright rights and
those that are short of that?
You know, when we talk
about type of contract
that says you can't sell a book
for less than a dollar forever
that would be expanding your
traditional rights, right?
But some of these other, you
know, licenses that we talk
about are short of the full-term
of copyright, for example.
You know, you could use a work
let's say it's a downloaded textbook
on your Kindle for the
term of your semester.
Is there a distinction there?
>> John Bergmayer: Well, I mean,
I think the reason we keep talking
about this in the copyright context
is because of the RAM copy doctrine,
which says that if
you're not the owner,
you need a license to use a product.
And that's not true in any
other context, you know?
Even if I don't own a
book, even if I stole it,
simply reading it does not
constitute an infringement.
But in the case of software,
if you're not the owner
of the physical item, the
material object of the copy,
you need a license and therefore all
sorts of crazy conditions can be put
on that license and simply
infringing anyone of them could lead
to an instance of copyright
infringement.
And it's a very software-specific
notion that comes
out of this concept that simply to
use a product in its ordinary course
of operation, somehow
triggers copyright.
And that's true uniquely in software
and I think that's why this is
a software-specific problem.
I'm not going to say that
there can't be other problems
with over broad contracts
or licenses, but, you know,
I'm just really focused on
this concept of ownership
and RAM copies leading to, you know,
minor infractions, perhaps leading
to copyright infringement in the
case that's unique to software.
>> Michelle Choe: Well, we
should get some more thoughts
on these issues.
So, let's move on to Mr. Mohr.
>> Chris Mohr: Yeah, there's--
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
Turn on your--
>> Chris Mohr: Several
points that look nothing
like what I was originally
going to say.
A couple of things, I mean, first
of all I think there has been
a fair amount of healthy candor
that the complaints
going on here far broader
than what this examination
is supposed to be about,
which is embedded software.
And these are complaints
about licensing generally.
I've seen reflected a greater
degree of certainty than I have
about whether a particular
restriction will trigger
infringement liability, because
there are covenants and conditions.
And covenants trigger
contractual liability
and conditions will trigger
infringement liability.
And so-- And then in that
context even if the infringement--
even if there's an
allege of infringement,
I honestly don't know the answers
to whether an affirmative defense
in that particular situation
might excuse that infringement
and then lead only to
a contract liability.
I don't know the answer
off the top of my head.
But I think that's the way that--
that's one way that the
courts could resolve this.
The second thing that I confess
some confusion to is knowing
when a sale and a license occurs.
The problem is that there
seems to be some belief
that there's a unified field
theory of software licensing
and that every-- most-- It's true.
Most pieces of software
are licensed,
but there are situations
when they're not.
And the courts have done a
good job at sorting that out,
different facts, different
results, different types of media
with particular different commercial
customs, different results.
That seems to here have
worked reasonably well.
And so, now, they-- our friends
have problems with the existence
of licensing generally, and
that's fine, but there's no--
it's a big jump to say from
there that, OK, well, you know,
embedded software is
a special problem
that needs special
rules, it doesn't.
And I think that's-- I'm not sure
that Congress necessarily agrees
with that premise and
certainly the courts haven't.
And then there's-- finally there was
two little things about ownership
that I wanted to mention.
The first has to do with
unforeseen consequences.
I mean, I think one of the reasons
that open source software works is
that because the license
restrictions run with the copy.
And so, if someone becomes an
owner of a particular copy,
they're no longer bound by
the license restrictions.
So at that point, how does
the community survive?
What's the incentive
for the community--
for the open source
community to survive?
And the second thing that distract
me, again, in sort of making it
out that there's this, oh, there's
this software boogieman that--
I'm not sure that's
right either because--
and an example of that is 512.
There are all kinds of works
now that are reproduced in RAM.
That's not unique to software.
And that may be a problem
that our friends have
with the copyright generally.
But again, that protection
of content
on computer networks is
frankly essential to many of my
and other folks-- member's
well-being.
And that's not-- that is not
a particular provision the law
that were inclined to reexamine
our application, rather.
>> Catherine Rowland: I had
a follow up question for you.
>> Chris Mohr: Yup.
>> Catherine Rowland: I guess anyone
who comes out for you about the--
So we're-- here, we're really
trying to limit this to this kind
of consumer products and embedded
software, which has we heard
from the first panel is
apparently very difficult
if possible at all to draw.
But a lot of this discussion
is really way beyond that kind
of situation and Vernor and Krauss
[assumed spelling], they both dealt
with the software itself.
So you're selling-- you
know, there was a license
for the actual software
versus a sale.
And I wonder what the
opinions would be or the kind
of legal analysis could be
based on something else,
like you buy the refrigerator,
it has some sort of software
to make the ice cubes
come out or whatnot.
When you buy the refrigerator you're
not signing a license or anything,
it just kind of coming
through and kind
of what the different
analysis might be.
>> Chris Mohr: I think
in that context, I mean,
the analysis would be-- I would
expect it to be context-specific.
So in other words, all of
those decisions would be made
against a backdrop of sales of goods
that have occurred for decades.
And so, I agree, I
think slapping a label
on a refrigerator saying this
refrigerator is licensed,
I'm not sure that would--
I'm not sure that would work.
But that's not what's
really happening.
I mean, when that refrigerator
contains, essentially,
a functioning computer and
that computer starts develop--
results in a continuing relationship
with the software provider,
for example, over, I don't
know, what you had in--
what the UPC codes are and you're--
that you put in your refrigerator
and now it knows what you've been
eating, how often you're eating,
whether or not you're off your
diet plan, all of these other kinds
of personal information,
that's an appropriate--
very appropriate situation
for a license agreement.
That is also a way that the
manufacturer maintains the integrity
of its product by kind of
setting the terms under which
that relationship occurs
or entitled to do that.
And if consumers don't like
that relationship, there is no--
they can go and buy
different refrigerator.
That's why we don't see this
as a-- you know, we don't--
as a group, we generally
don't see a problem here,
it seems to be working OK.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr. Zuck.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Thanks.
You do come around past what
we thought you're going to say
by the time the discussion evolves.
But I think that, again,
taking a kind of step back,
there's the entire history of
the software industry that comes
into play when looking
at one of the--
some of the standard practices
that we see like, you know,
prohibitions on reverse engineering.
And you have to remember that that's
a legacy of tremendous amounts
of software piracy and people
just trying to empower themselves
in any way possible to try
and stem the flow of that.
I also think that it's a little
bit specious to say that a copy--
a digital copy of something
is really to same thing
as a physical object, and where
this really bares itself out is
that the enterprises, for example,
have one copy of a piece of software
and can buy multiple
licenses for its use.
These are different keys, et cetera,
that I put in to make
use of the software.
So it's a little bit like you're
allowed to make as a many copies
of this encrypted book as you
want to, but what I'm going
to sell you is the key that allows
you to decrypt, you know, the--
which letters to read to read the
book or something like that, right?
And so, I think there is a
distinction that it has allowed
for very dynamic business
in terms of business models,
whether the example you brought
in terms of educational pricing,
enterprise pricing, et cetera,
there's different support plans,
there's also a history of support
for software that's very different
than it is for physical products.
And there's reputational
things to consider as well.
I mean, we have a member drink mate
that actually made an overt attempt
to have an open license for people
to create different versions
of the implementation software
on what is essentially a personal
breathalyzer device, right?
And what they found over time
is that they weren't able
to maintain a standard of
quality among these sort
of publicly provided
versions of software devices
and they suffered a reputational
harm as a result, and had to
and were only enable to because
of it being a license to bring
that back in house and make sure
that only their software was
associated with those devices,
we saw that they could recuperate
from that reputational
harm that they suffered.
So I think there's a lot
that's unique about software.
I think as we move forward
into the internet of things
and embedded software and devices,
you're going to see more
experimentation in business models,
and some of the legacy practices
will start to fall away because some
of the legacy dangers will
fall away at the same time.
But I think all of that is going
to happen much more quickly
into much more dynamic
fashion than any kind
of legislative effort would happen.
So again, as we said
in the last panel,
I think that the existing mechanisms
that are in place both in terms
of contract law and copyright
exceptions, provide a more fluid
and a better place to
deal with these issues
than some kind of legislative
solution.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr.
Perzanowski, I think you're in
and we'll go to Mr. Bockert.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: So there
are a couple of distinctions
that I think are useful to draw
that I think at some points
in our discussion have
been confused.
So first I think we
need to distinguish
between licensing software and
licensing copies of software.
And these are two very
different things.
I also think we have to distinguish
between questions of interpreting
and enforcing contracts
on the one hand,
and what I think should be the
crucial question for this discussion
which is how we determine whether a
transfer of ownership has occurred,
when it comes to particular
copies of software, right.
And one place I think it make sense
to look is the statute itself.
You know, unfortunately, for
better or maybe for worse,
the copyright act does
not define ownership
in the context of consumers.
It doesn't define transfers
of ownership.
But there is language that's useful
in this interpretive question,
and that language is
in 1063 itself, right?
1063 defines the kinds
of distributions,
the copyright law recognizes when
it comes to particular copies,
and it divides the universe
into two kinds of distributions.
There are sales and other transfers
of ownership on the one hand,
and there is rental, lease,
and lending on the other.
So, every transfer of a copy,
every distribution of a copy,
is either a transfer of ownership
or it's a rental, a
lease, or a lending.
That's really clear
from the statute.
So the question is if someone wants
to license a copy, which one is it?
And I think if you look at it
from that perspective it's actually
a much easier question to answer,
into the idea of a licensed
copy, is really a myth, right?
That's not a real thing.
It's not a transactional form
that the copyright act recognizes.
You might say that there are
certain kinds of leases or rentals
or lendings that you want to use
the label license to characterize,
but there's no such
thing as a licensed copy.
The software industry has
been pretty successful
in convincing some courts
that that's a real thing.
>> Sy Damle: But how
would you-- Sorry.
How would you explain why is then,
where they essentially had
perpetual possession of the movie,
the film prints, but
under restrictions.
And the courts are--
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
You're talking about Wise?
>> Sy Damle: Yeah, Wise.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: So
we could characterize--
we could look at the facts of
Wise and say that that is a lease,
that that is a lending, that there
are certain restrictions, right?
So, what is it that separates a
transfer of ownership from one
of these other kinds of more
temporary time limited transactions?
And it might be an
ongoing obligation to pay.
It might be that there is some
sort of durational limit, right,
at some point you've got
to give the thing back.
That fits, I think, reasonably
well into the common understanding
of leasing or rental, right?
It's not a transfer of ownership,
if when the thing is given
to you it is made explicitly clear
that at a certain point you have
to return the item, you
have to destroy the item,
that's not a transfer
of ownership, right?
Ownership entails perpetual
possession,
no ongoing obligation to pay.
When those two factors are present,
what you have is a transfer
of ownership, right?
>> Sy Damle: So is it your
position that both Vernor
and Krauss are incorrect?
Not the decision but the reasoning
of both of those cases is incorrect?
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
I'm happy to say
that the reasoning in
Vernor is incorrect.
I think the reasoning
in Krauss is less clear
than it should be, although I'm--
>> Sy Damle: But Krauss
acknowledged that there could be--
I mean it didn't find the license
in that case but it acknowledged
that there could be licenses.
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
Yeah that's right.
Yeah, I think the conceptual
framework that courts used
to answer this question is confused.
A couple of other points here.
You know, one of the questions
that came up is, you know,
what's the value of a license
that purports to deny a transfer
of ownership to a consumer?
And there's a lot of value there.
It's value that I think
we should question
from an overall social
utility standpoint, right?
It's about restricting resale,
it's about controlling
aftermarket products,
it is about controlling
the market for services.
It might be about price
discrimination
and we can have a debate about the
merits of price discrimination.
There are other means other
than denying consumers the right
to own the things that
they purchased
to achieve price discrimination.
I think it's worth pointing out that
the Supreme Court was really clear
in Kirtsaeng that price
discrimination is not among the
rights that copyright holders get to
enjoy by virtue of their copyright.
So if--
>> Sy Damle: If you would
acknowledge that there are--
I mean this is sort of like
basic economics, right?
I mean there are consumer
benefits to allowing
for price discrimination.
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
There certainly can be,
but I would not say that price
discrimination is necessarily
overall to the benefit of consumers.
There are certain circumstances
where price discrimination it is
in fact very useful for consumers.
But denying consumers' ownership
and imposing ongoing copyright
obligations is not the only way
to price discriminate.
There are lots of industries
that price discriminate
that don't use copyright
law whatsoever.
And, you know, I think we've
seen in the wake of Kirtsaeng
that price discrimination
in the market
for academic textbooks continues.
There are other ways
of achieving that goal.
One way of achieving that goal is to
not sell products to people, right?
Don't engage in transactions
that look like sales.
Engage in transactions that look
like subscriptions
that look like rentals.
You know, my students have the
option to get their case books
in law school on a
rental model, right,
or on an ongoing subscription model.
That at least is an honest way
of engaging with consumers.
You're not characterizing
in a transaction as a sale
when in fact you don't
believe that it's a sale.
You know, those kinds
of transactions carry
with them expectations
that consumers think they're
getting a certain set of rights
when they buy a product, right?
When you go and you buy that new
refrigerator, you think you own it.
You don't think you're entering
into an ongoing relationship
with the service provider, right?
That's what you do with
your cable company.
I won't say more about what people
think of their cable companies.
You know, but when you buy a
refrigerator, you think you own it.
You think you have a
certain set of rights.
I just-- I have a study that
was just published last Friday
that looks at this question in the
context of digital media that looks
at the Buy Now button used
prominently by Amazon and Apple,
and finds that consumers believe
they have the right to engage
in a resale with digital media
that they buy now to lend
that digital media to
others to give it away,
to leave it in their will, right?
So when you set up a transaction,
when you present it to consumers
in the context of a sale,
they have expectations
about what they're getting.
And the fact that some
license agreement that no one
in their right mind would invest
the time to read, you know,
includes terms to the contrary
does not change those consumer
expectations, right?
So, this isn't to say that we can't
allow for flexible business models
that give software companies
the kinds of protections
that they think they need.
You can look at what Adobe has done
with its Creative Suite
over the last few years.
You can't buy it anymore.
You can pay Adobe $50 a month
for the rest of your life
if you're creative professional
to use their software.
And in a lot of ways, I think
that was really smart
decision on their part, right?
It avoids the problems
that they saw with resale.
It allows them a, you know,
more predictable revenue stream.
It allows them to deliver
product updates
to consumers in a more
effective way.
And it's a really honest
transaction.
You know what you're
getting from the outset.
>> Sy Damle: So is this the
problem that's going to diminish
as we go forward, because
as we move, you know,
more and more into kind of
cloud-based services the sort
of problems that you've identified
are kind of problems of the moment.
But, you know, we have Office 365,
there's like all sorts of other ways
in which where now
software is moving
into like cloud-based
subscription models.
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
So in some ways--
>> Sy Damle: And then the reason I'm
asking that is because, you know,
if we're looking ahead, if we're
solving yesterday's problem,
it doesn't make very much sense.
>> Erik Bertin: I'm sorry.
Can I just add one
point on top of that?
I mean the Adobe example you
cite is a good one but sort
of the logic behind your
argument is that the physicality
of the Adobe product is gone.
There is no longer a CD
that you're purchasing.
It's-- You're just simply
downloading the product,
as opposed to your
refrigerator which is physical
in every sense the, the
word, it's going to be
with you for a long time.
So is there a distinction there?
>> Aaron Perzanowski: Yeah.
Well, I think in the Adobe example,
you're not buying anything, right?
That transaction is absolutely on
the rental, lease, or lending side
of this divide in Section 1063.
So I don't think there's
any good argument
that the consumer owns anything.
You know, they're paying
for a service.
In terms of whether this
is yesterday's problem
or tomorrow's problem, in
some ways I think for markets
for pure software products,
we are going to see a move
in this direction towards
cloud-based services.
The area where I think
we need to be focusing
as I think we are here
today, is what happens
when we see software
embedded in everyday products
that consumers use everyday, right?
There, there is necessarily a
kind of a physical embodiment
of the work and of the product.
And so, in those circumstances,
I don't think you can escape these
questions, right, because the nature
of the product embeds
that kind of physicality.
And unless we start to see-- which
I'm doubtful about, unless we start
to see really explicit shift to now
you don't buy your home appliances,
you lease your home
appliances, we're going to have
to face this question of who
owns the software that makes
that product work, right?
The software is just as important
to the functioning of your car
or your new smart refrigerator
or your smart TV as any
of the physical component.
So to tell consumers, sure, you own
the plastic and you own the chips
and you own the display,
but the thing that actually
makes the thing work,
the thing that actually
makes the thing valuable,
someone else controls that.
That puts consumers in a really
precarious situation, right?
Think about-- I missed the
beginning of the first panel,
so I'm sure someone has
already mentioned revolve.
But look at what happened
with that device.
Consumers went out, they
bought this device for $300,
this home automation hub.
They thought they owned it.
They thought they got to use it as
long as they wanted until one day,
they got a message that said, "Oh,
that thing you bought,
it's a brick," right?
It's useless now.
Because they don't own and
they don't control the software
that makes it operate.
That puts consumers in a
really precarious position.
So, you know, I'm worried
about a future
where consumers have this illusion
of ongoing personal property rights
that they have enjoyed,
you know, for centuries.
But what's really going on
and what they will learn only
when it is too late is that
they really have no control
over the objects that surround
them and that they rely on.
>> Michelle Choe: So first
I'm going to announce
that we're extending the panel
since there're some really
good thoughts being discussed
but going sort of towards what
you've been talking about,
how has an-- and this is for
you and everyone else sort
of how has this played
out in the market.
I think you mentioned-- I don't
know if this is sort of actual data
but the possibility of
the refrigerator and that
if consumers are unhappy with
the restrictions that come
with that refrigerator that
they can just buy a refrigerator
from a different seller.
And, you know, in the comments there
is the example of the Keurig device
where people were upset with their
restrictions sort of set forth
by Keurig and they decided
for PR reasons to move forward
in a different direction.
So I'm really curious sort
of how the market, you know,
plays out in this sphere.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: I think the
short answer is it's too early
to tell.
You know, this is all
developing as we speak.
There have been instances where
consumers were up in arms enough
about a particular restriction that
they could effectively, you know,
move the needle in terms
of how a company responds.
There have been other examples
where that hasn't been the case.
Frankly, the big problem is these
restrictions do not become clear
to consumers until they are faced
with a device that doesn't behave
as they expected to, right?
So, you know, the revolve
I, I think, the clearest
and most recent example of that.
It's not the only one of the comment
that I submitted includes a
long list of consumer devices
where these kinds of problems
have presented themselves.
So, I'm not willing today to
say that the market is going
to be capable of solving
these problems.
I think in some instances it
will and in many it won't.
>> Michelle Choe: So why don't
we move on to Mr. Bockert?
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
So, I think the--
>> Erik Bertin: If you just
turn on your microphone.
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Sorry.
So the refrigerator
example is a good one.
And you confront a variation
of the problem or this issue
in almost every merger
and acquisition
where you have a buyer going in
and saying I want all
your refrigerators,
you know, in this facility.
And you know, in the back of
your mind, you're like, well,
each of these refrigerators
has the software in it
that when you press the button
that shoots out the ice, right?
And you go to the seller and you
say I'd love to see the license
that covers the software that shoots
out the ice in your refrigerators.
And the seller, of course, says
I either had it and I lost it
or it doesn't exist at
all, they just don't know.
And then as a buyer, you have
to ask the question, you know,
"Am I allowed to acquire this?
Is now the owner of that
software going to hold me up--
hold up the transaction
perhaps have a, you know,
a special transaction fee just
to allow it to go through?"
And, you know, in refrigerators it
may be an easy example because it's
like small amounts of money but the
larger the product gets, you know,
we can start adding
up a lot more money.
And I think the idea is
we already have, you know,
the concepts especially, you
know, imported from patent law
like the doctrine of
exhaustion, where we can say maybe
in certain cases with software, when
it's embedded in a consumer product
and it acts in a certain way
in that consumer product,
maybe the doctrine of
exhaustion can apply.
So we can say, look, you
know, this is what it's doing
in that refrigerator,
therefore, you know,
the sale can go on,
it runs with the good.
>> Michelle Choe: And why
don't we move back this way.
Mr. Zuck.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Sure.
I know we're running
a little bit long.
I guess, again, I get back to
the notion that there's a lot
of dynamism sort of
in the marketplace.
And so if you look TiVo
as another example,
they were practically giving away
hardware that was in conjunction
with software as a
service that allowed
for programming and
storage of content.
And so, I mean, embedded in
that business model was sort
of like basically subsidizing
the hardware
with what was a software license.
And again, I think that you're going
to potentially see things like that
with refrigerators that
there's a service or, you know,
you connected the way or
something like that associated
with your refrigerator and
its monitoring capabilities.
And I can't foresee what all
of those models are going
to be but I can imagine them.
And I think to some extent,
we're going to have to rely
on requirements for notice and
things like that to take the place
of trying to jigger the law around.
And again, I come back to that being
the fundamental question you're
asking is whether or not there's
some fundamental change to be made
to copyright law to accommodate
what is an incredibly dynamic market
but incredibly dynamic
business models.
And as I said, as the risks
associated with piracy change
as the needs for consumers change,
I think the market will evolve
in such a way that it
will address these things.
I mean, the number of people
that are really affected
by the license agreement in the
refrigerator in their inability
to sell it, at least to
date, is not existent, right?
I mean people have been selling
devices and cars to each other
that have software embedded
than for the most part.
And so, again, until we really
have an identifiable problem,
I think we shouldn't be
looking ahead to the solution
because we'll get it wrong.
>> Michelle Choe: And Mr. Mohr.
>> Chris Mohr: Two responses,
I guess two hopefully
pretty quick points.
All right, well, so the first has to
do with the idea of licensing copies
on which the entire open source
and software industry is based.
A wise man once said-- and
I think it was John Bond--
that, you know, if all the courts
come out against you've got
to entertain the possibility
that you're wrong.
And in this particular instance,
I mean, that's the way all
of the cases have come out.
You know, that is the-- that's
a legal reality we live in.
That's a reality that
works quite well.
Again, it's the model that open
source depends on and a lot
of our other members
depend on to make money.
The second thing I would
suggest is to be careful--
very careful when you analyze
these issues about getting confused
between issues of consumer
protection
and issues of copyright law.
So it is true that if you
in certain circumstance,
in a specific transactional
context, that the presence
of a Buy Now button could
convey an impression
that is misleading or deceptive.
And it is also true the same
can be said of many things,
for example, campaign commercials.
It does not follow from that
that there is any problem
with the copyright
system whatsoever.
And I think it's important
to draw that line
between a particular practice in a
particular context, and this is one
of the things that the PTO is
going to look at because this came
up in the context of
their study and some kind
of inherent problem
with licensing itself.
I think those are two
very different inquiries.
That's it.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr. Harbeson.
>> Eric Harbeson: I want to go back
to the refrigerator and point that,
yes, the consumer can go
find a different refrigerator
if she has a problem
with the licensing,
but she still needs
the refrigerator,
and if all of the refrigerators
can carry that--
some kind of unacceptable
license, she's out of luck.
Now, to use that to once again
beg the room's indulgence,
in the case of sound recording
of a musical work it's
the only sound recording.
It's a monopoly.
This is why this is
related to copyright.
If you're the only-- If you
have the exclusive right
to that particular sound
recording and my library needs
that particular sound recording,
there is no other way I can get it.
That's where the consumer
protections fail.
There is no way for the
library to serve this material.
And another thing that I've heard
brought up but may have been
in an earlier panel, and
I'm sorry, if it was.
But the idea that software
licenses are--
well, the software
products are updated so fast
and their lifespan was so
short that they really aren't--
they aren't a long-term problem.
But with sound recordings which
last hopefully hundreds of years--
in some cases they lasted
more than a hundred, anyway--
a license that doesn't have an
expiration will become a problem
for a very long time.
And so, again, I really would like
to encourage everyone to think
about this as a problem
that's much bigger
than simply software-enabled
consumer products.
The folks that I represent are not--
do not have a problem
with licensing per se.
The idea of iTunes model providing
licensed copies begging your pardon
to consumers directly for 99 cents
and having all of those terms
and conditions is not
actually our problem.
The problem is when libraries
specifically are excluded
from that process and are unable
to include culturally extremely
significant works in our collections
and those works die out as
soon as the service dies out.
>> Erik Bertin: OK.
Thank you.
>> Michelle Choe: Oh.
And--
>> Aaron Lowe: So I want to
address the issue of, you know,
whether you go out and
buy another product.
When you purchase a vehicle,
you're spending $30,000,
$40,000 for that car.
The information that's available to
you about the repair of that car,
the licensing is not entirely
apparent to you, too, until you have
to actually go through it.
And then you find your, you
know, now subject to the fact
that you don't own that vehicle.
The licensing hasn't
really occurred but--
and it's part of the
1201 discussions
that the car companies raised
the fact that they felt
that when you purchased
a car you are--
the owner who was licensing
that software didn't
necessarily own the software
that was on that vehicle.
That created a huge
firestorm in itself and--
within our industry
and with consumers.
And I think that, you know, cars
are around for multiple years.
What happens to these
cars, they change hands,
parts are taken off these
cars with software on them
and then they're remanufactured
by individual companies,
that then what happens
to that software company,
they reuse that software
on that remanufactured part
because the part itself needs to
have that software to operate.
Those are all questions
that I think are--
that needed to be answered as well.
But I don't believe that, you know,
you can simple say that you're going
to just buy-- if you buy a Ford
you don't like the whole deal,
you could go out and buy
a Chrysler next time,
because simply you're pretty much
stuck with that car for a while
and the servicing on that vehicle.
>> Michelle Choe: Do
you feel like the market
in that area hasn't
addressed those issues?
I'd recall sort of there
being some press on some
of the car companies
considering those issues
and those concerns and coming to.
I believe those are
memorandum of understanding
when it comes to, you know--
>> Aaron Lowe: Yeah, we came to
a memorandum of understanding
on the right to repair, which meant
that all the information tools
and software supposed to be
available to a repair shop
to be able to repair that car
but that doesn't necessarily
cover the part itself.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr. Kupferschmid.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Thank you.
And I guess maybe we can talk
about the different product
other than refrigerators.
We're so close to lunch time.
I don't know about you, I'm
getting a little hungry.
To address a few points
that Professor Perzanowski--
if I'm pronouncing
that right-- discussed.
He had some-- took some
issue with the Vernor case
but at the same point talked about
how you distinguished lending
from a sale and the fact that
lending-- and I'm pretty sure--
this is a quote-- there
are certain limitations.
If you look at the Vernor case it's
part-- there's a three-pronged test
and that includes that the license
include limitations on the transfer
but also limitations on use,
and that would sort of seem
to satisfy that requirement.
It was also raised about, you know,
the question are we trying the
solve yesterday's problems?
And I could not agree
more with that.
For some reason we
have this fascination,
love affair with destruction
and return of the product,
and hitting the Buy Now
or buy button and people--
or consumers are confused
about that.
I think it depends on the consumers.
I think if you were to have my
17-year-old son sitting here instead
of me, I think he'd say
there's no confusion whatsoever
because he's grown up in an
environment that's very different.
If you look at-- I mean, and
this issue is not specific
to copyright either if you hit the
buy button when you're buying a seat
on an airplane, but I
don't think anybody thinks
that they're actually
buying that seat.
And so, I think that terminology has
just been used because it's easier
for consumers to understand.
We talked about these sort of long
use and long licenses and it's
so difficult for consumers
to understand.
The idea is everyone is trying
to make it easier for consumers.
And if you have these
long descriptions of the--
within the button I think that would
certainly make it more difficult.
And then just the last thing I just
reiterate, which is already said.
To the extent that the software
license is embedded in software--
because remember, that's what
we're talking about here--
are being misused or
abused, the market is
and will be self-correcting.
In our comments we mention
the Keurig example, OK?
And that applies here.
If you're engaging-- If a software
or a hardware manufacturer
is engaging in sort
of anti-consumer behavior, they're
not going to be around very long.
And if the manufacturer is
dealing with a software company
and that software company is just
trying to enforce their license
in way that the manufacturer--
device manufacturer isn't
particularly pleased with, well,
that relationship is not going
to last very long either.
So there are-- in terms of
the market and relationships,
there are self-correcting
mechanisms in there
if in fact these problems
were to continue to occur
or can occur going into the future.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr. Band.
>> Jonathan Band: So, a lot of
people have raised the issue of sort
that there's this continuing
relationship
that you're really not
getting a software as a product
but a software as a device.
And that certainly might be true
with respect to some of the software
and the devices that
we're talking about.
I mean, it could very well
be that in your computer
that there is one piece of
software that is compute--
you know, communicating to the
central server somewhere in the sky
and telling them that you are,
you know, eating too much.
But I think there's going to
be a lot of other software
in the refrigerator and certainly
a lot of other software in the car,
and all of these replaced--
all of these parts that Mr. Lowe has
been talking about that communicate
with one another where they're
not interacting with, you know,
with the cloud that they're just
interacting with other parts
of the car and you'll have the
software that's interacting
with other parts of
the refrigerator.
And I think it's important to
sort of try to keep this issue--
you know, keep those separate.
Because I agree that if there
is an ongoing relationship
that poses different issues.
Now part of it, you know, there's
related issues like are you paying
for the ongoing relationships?
Certainly if you're
paying, you know,
the subscription fee every
month, that's one thing.
If there's a sort of a
paid-up license that--
you know, paid-up license at the
beginning where it's understood
that you're-- you know, for
the life of a refrigerator,
it will always be communicating
with the cloud, you know,
that might be different situation
and maybe in that case, you know,
you have-- you know, the person
about the refrigerator has a
different bundle of rights.
But it certainly seems to me that if
we're talking about sort of software
that is-- you know, where there is
no ongoing relationship, I mean,
that seems to be much easier case
to say, OK, let's figure out how
to deal with that situation.
In other words, you know,
there's a bit of a spectrum here,
a spectrum of relationship.
There could be situations
where there's absolutely none,
there could be a situation where
there's a very tight relationship
with the ongoing subscription,
and then you have situations
in the middle where
there might be some sort
of ongoing relationship
but it's all paid up.
And those are three very different
situations that I think can be--
>> Sy Damle: So do you think that--
I mean, to me that suggest that we
should really careful about trying
to be establish rules in this
area and that may be something
that we should let courts sort
out on a case by case basis.
I mean, do you disagree with that?
>> Jonathan Band: Yes.
Because I think it is
possible to come up with rules.
Certainly where there is no
ongoing relationship, whatsoever,
I think that's a very
easy case, you know,
and we could come up
with rules today.
And if fact, you know,
to some extent that's what
[inaudible] tries to do that.
It tried to be very careful.
And one of the things that,
you know, in the conversations
with Congressman Farenthold's
office that, you know,
came up with exactly this but
what about the updates, right?
And so there were some folks who
said, well, you know, if you--
you know, and again we're only
dealing with the contemplations
when you have a paid-up
license, when it's all--
you know, you pay once
upfront, no ongoing payments.
And so, should you be
when you sell it to the--
you know, when the device is sold to
the second person, what do they get
in terms of software going forward?
And there were some folks who were
very interested in saying, well,
you should be able to get
whatever the first person
or whatever the first purchaser
would have gotten if it had stayed
in that person's possession.
So, to the extent that there would
have been ongoing updates, then,
you know, the second purchaser
should be able to get everything
that the first purchaser had
bought-- would have gotten.
But actually, you know,
the ultimate conclusion--
again, not necessarily that
our numbers would have wanted--
was that now you only got bug
fixes and security patches.
You don't get the new releases,
so that-- you know, that there's--
that you are-- even though you would
have paid upfront and if it stayed
with the first person that would
have gotten any new release,
the idea is that, you
know, because the sense was
that there is this ongoing
relationship and it's sort
of different that you don't get
the full bundle you get less.
But the point is that these are ones
that Congress is perfectly
capable of drawing.
>> Sy Damle: That line
seems particular--
That seems like a very difficult
line to apply and practice
if I'm a software company, you know,
oftentimes on bundling bug fixes
with, you know, new releases,
so I'm adding new features
and I'm adding bug fixes
and sometimes they're
sort of integrated--
>> Jonathan Band: Well, so if the
copyright office wants to recommend
that it should just be-- you should
get everything the first purchaser
wanted and, you know, that you
should get all the new releases,
that would be great.
>> Sy Damle: I mean, you know, but
that again goes back to the question
of whether there's like
a practical concern here.
I mean, you know, just
looking on eBay to see
if I can buy a used Nest thermostat.
And you can.
And I'm not-- So going again
to the fact that this is
about consumer products
if there is not problem--
a demonstrated problem
in the marketplace,
I'm not sure just looking it
from Congress' perspective
that they're particularly would
be interested in trying to jump
into this kind of thorny issue.
So again, just to reiterate to the
extent we have specific examples
of this occurring in the context of
consumer devices not in the context
of sort of business-to-business
type transactions,
I think that would be something
we'd be very interested
in finding out about.
>> Michelle Choe: Mr. Bergmayer.
>> John Bergmayer: OK.
You know, just for the record,
open source software is not
dependent of licensing copies.
It's dependent on licensing
intellectual property rights,
that the licensee otherwise would
not have in placing conditions
on those rights, which
is totally legit.
So, for example, the GPL grants
to the licensee the right
to make reproductions or the
right to make derivative works.
Licensees don't otherwise
have those rights.
So putting conditions
on those is fine.
And I don't have an
objection to that.
Those licenses do not
depend on saying
that the ultimate user does not own
a copy of the software in question.
I think that is very
important distinction.
Second, I think, you know,
let's say for the sake
of argument that I own this iPhone.
When I install an app on it, I
think I own a copy of that app.
A copy is defined is the
statute as a material thing,
the only material thing
I see is the iPhone,
therefore I necessarily own a copy.
I don't think there are
negative consequences of that
for the software developer.
What does it mean?
It means I can operate the software
without needing a specific license
by virtue of the essential step
test, the essential step doctrine
which says that I'm entitled to
make RAM copies that are necessary
to use physical items that I own.
I don't think that's bad
for software developers.
And it might mean that
first-sale applies.
But as a practical matter in
today's technological environment,
what I'm going to do?
Sell my entire phone
including my iTunes account?
That's really not going to happen.
I think it could happen if I were
to sell my iPhone including
my iTunes Store account
that is tied to.
I think I should be allowed
to do that and I think that's
where first-sale kicks in.
But as a practical matter, you
know, first-sale doesn't entitle me
to make arbitrary numbers of
new copies and resell them.
It doesn't entitle me to engage
in piracy in any respect.
In fact, the main thing that saying
that I own a copy of software
that I bought even in the case
of an Adobe Creative Cloud situation
is simple to say that simply
by virtue of owning it, I don't
need a license just to use it.
It doesn't grant any new rights.
It doesn't necessarily
even entitle me
to software updates in the future.
And I don't think that is
bad for a software developer,
and I have a hard time seeing
why there is such resistance
to this concept which is grounded
in a claim text of the statute
that one, copies are
material items, and two,
if I own the material
item I own the copy.
I don't-- I have very difficulty--
a very much difficulty in seeing
the resistance to that except
for the fact that by saying
that you don't own the copy,
that brings up the RAM copy's
doctrine and it allows you
to put all kinds of restrictions and
sort of gin up copyright violations
for what otherwise be a
routine contract violation.
So, those are my two final points.
>> Erik Bertin: So
again, is it your --
I'm going to ask you
the same question asked,
Mr. Perzanowski before.
Is it your view that both--
in the sense both Krauss and Vernor
had it wrong when they suggested
that there could be
licenses for software?
>> Aaron Perzanowski: In the
case that I don't own software,
it's because I don't
own the material item.
So when you're saying
that I don't own the film,
that means I don't own the film
stock, there's no third way.
There's IP rights and
there's material copies,
there is no like ethereal
copy that is somehow a part
from the material object
and has nothing to do
with traditional 106 rights.
>> Erik Bertin: Yeah, I know.
I understand that point.
But both Krauss and Vernor
proceeded from the assumption
that there could be
licenses and copies.
And they reached different
results at the end
of the day looking at the facts.
But I think they both
have that same basic--
>> John Bergmayer: So I think to
use the helpful terminology in any
of those cases if you're saying
that I have license to copy,
what you're saying is that the
material object is something
that I don't really own because
I'm just borrowing something
and that's fine and that's
not unique to software.
>> Erik Bertin: All right.
Thank you.
>> Michelle Choe: We'll
conclude with Mr. Perzanowski.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: I'll
try to be really brief.
So, I want to come back to
the point that Chris made
which I think is really important.
And I agree that for the most part,
these kinds false advertising
concerns
that I raised are legally distinct
from the kinds of questions
that we're trying to answer here.
There is one way that I do think
they're relevant and it comes back
to a point I think you made
earlier which is that, you know,
one of the reasons that the software
cases seem to come out differently
from the other kinds of, you know,
license versus sale questions
with other types of media is
that maybe we think there
is something different
about business practices,
about the history,
and about consumer
expectations in software markets.
I'm not entirely convinced
of that argument.
If that's true, though,
it cuts both waves, right?
If consumers are used to
licenses when it comes
to standalone software,
they're not used to licenses
when it come to refrigerators,
right?
So we should about that line
of reasoning not only in terms
of how it applies looking
backward but in terms
forward into the areas
where consumers have no expectation,
whatsoever, of licensing
and whether there is no history
of a practice of licensing.
To come back to Keith's
point, the great thing
about doing empirical research
is you don't have to suppose
or imagine you get like
answers to questions.
And it turns out that young white
men are in fact more confused
than anyone about what
the Buy Now button means,
and it turns out that providing
a bullet-pointed short notice
significantly reduces the degree
to which consumers
misunderstand the rights.
The papers up on SSRN, if anybody's
interested, I recommend you read it
because I do think there is
value from having real evidence
and not just imagining
the way the role might be.
>> Michelle Choe: Great.
So we're going to take
15-minute break.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.